hello everyone and welcome back to the
2020 Tata Steel masters edition it's
round nine and it's the clash you've all
been waiting for Ali Riza fallujah vs.
Magnus Carlsen so ali reza currently in
the lead and magnus following one point
behind if ali reza can draw this game or
or maybe even win it it will be well it
will mean wonders for for his standings
in the tournament for his rating for
well basically for everything and for
cousin he's just well taking on another
challenger and i ran a poll on Twitter
some three hours after the this game
started here I asked you what do you
think well the result will be 12.1
percent of you said eyelid as a
whirlwind forty nine point two of you
said Magnus will win and thirty eight
point eight of you I said that it will
be a draw so let's see let's see what
actually happened all it as I had the
white pieces and he opened with e4 and
it's I will point out that first time
Magnus Carlsen met with a World Chess
Champion in a classical game over the
board was also invite honza I it was
also the Tata Steel only it wasn't
Kolkata still back then it was called
the chorus a group and he faced Vladimir
Kramnik in 2007 Magnus had the black
pieces and the Magnus was able to get a
draw so let's see how Allah raised at us
and Magnus was some I believe some six
months younger than ollie Reza when he
faced a big Vlad so let's see let's see
how this goes with E for Magnus replies
with E 5 so we are definitely expecting
the Berlin Knight f3 Knight to c6 and
Bishop to b5 the reuleaux pieces on the
board Knight of 6 with d3 that and d6
now we have C 3 a6 pushing the bishop
back push up the a4 and now Bishop to e7
also g6 is being played here quite
frequently so Bishop to e7 early days of
castles Magnus castles and the rook to
e1 Magnus goes rook to e8 and now Knight
bTW 2 preparing Knights 2 f1 so all
standard rule opus stuff
the schibetta f8 and now comes h3 night
f1 is coming at some point we have b5 by
Magnus
go back to see to end now Bishop to b7
imagine suppose for the site service
system and now d4 by Alireza also
possible it is to go for a four it's a
3a for d4 or depending on what you
prefer
so d4 by Allah Reza and then only now g6
by Magnus we have a three and now Knight
back to b8 preparing to bust open the
position with c5 and here there are some
ways you can prevent this you can go
nice to the b3 you can go be for a lot
of possible ideas ELISA prefers d5 he
just grabs more space in the center and
Magnus immediately challenges this d5
pawn with c6 we have c4 alavesa wants to
keep his d5 central pawn and now Knight
back to d7 we have a four by Allah Reza
and now comes Queen to c7 here Magnus
wants to bring the other rook over to c8
and then make a capture here so after
captures there might be some problems
with with the bishop and c2 and here
Alisa took a very good thing some 23
minutes think and he played the absolute
best move in the position he played b3
we just keeps the tension and he says
okay you you figure out what you want to
play and the situation on the clock
already here is our ASA 39 minutes
Magnus has at one hour and 15 minutes so
rook eat the c8 already creating some
threats here now captures captures and
Queen CalPERS and c2 is the most obvious
threat but even if you move the bishop
it's it it is insufficient because after
Queen to c3 it comes with a double
attack here you don't actually win a
piece because after rook to a 2 you
cannot win the bishop due to rook to e3
this traps the Queen however you can
play Knight captures on d5 this is
possible so you just grab a pawn and
after each cap for Sundy 5 you now have
a an escape route for your queen so now
you capture it and if rook III now you
just pick up another pawn and you just
wrapped to two very important central
pawns which is basically game so these
are some of the threats that lurk in the
position so Ali Reza has to play a bit
of a passive move rook a to now he's not
worried off captures because the rook
now
the bishop on c2 with B captures on c4
and B captures on c4 here ali reza again
took some time deciding between B
captors and D captures on c6 you could
go for this Bishop captures and then try
capturing with the night but still after
the night comes to c5 it will just be a
very strong position for for black d5 is
coming at some point and it's it's
preferred for to be black here so just
be kept presence e4 by Allah Reza and
now a five by Magnus an important move
not allowing this pawn to be pushed even
further this Bishop is coming to a6
assuming this diagonal and this Bishop
is coming well to h6 assuming this
diagonal so this is this is Carson's
plan we have Knights the f1 by Allah
Reza's waiting to see what Carson will
do and now brush up the a six-course and
improves the position we have Knight
back the e3 by allah reza adding a
defender to the c4 pawn here and now
Knight the c5 by magnus so here black
already has a very very firm grip on the
position the e4 pawn is being threatened
so you have to do something about that
night back to d2 now with the knight
will nicely defend both of these pawns
and here Magnus trades once see captures
on d5 we seek a person d5 and now comes
Luke a to b8 you could go for a knight
to d3 right away but that's more of a
threat so you know as the saying goes
the the threat is stronger than then the
execution so keep it keep it in the air
so rook a to b8 putting the roof to a
nice open B file and now comes Bishop to
a3 by Alireza and again he took some
time here you could go for a natural
developing move like Queen f3 attacking
the knight here but then Knight h5 and
the knight wants to come to f4 which is
something Magnus was probably going to
do so it doesn't really change anything
you would have to kick it you would have
to prevent this with g3 and then you can
go night to d3 and so on and so on
Bishop captures Bishop captures and now
you have the the rooks just controlling
the the B and C file and it's just a
very very strong position for black so
here is again
decides to keep the tension bush up to a
three and now wind back to d8 by Magnus
already defending the night so he
doesn't have to worry about Queen f3 and
now the two rooks nicely control the BNC
file we have Queen to f3 and now comes
h5 taking away the g4 Square from Ella
Dez's night so he's unable to at the
trade off some pieces we have roped
eight a one now here ali reza brings the
rope back and he wants the trade at
least one pair of rooks along the B file
as you no longer need neither a rope
here to guard the bishop there aren't
any well for the moment there aren't any
discoveries to be made with the night
and the night from III also guards the
bishop and c2 so here
Bishop to h6 by Magnus now and not
allowing this Knight to move because
this bishop hangs here and now if you
look at Magnus bishop pair it really it
really is a bishop pair from hell
slicing the entire board in half
so rook eight abbi one Alireza offers a
trade along the B file but in the Magnus
obliges with rook a person be one with
rook captures on b1 and now King to g7
just adding more protection to the night
here and now the Queen can move so the
Queen doesn't have to defend the knife
and here the situation on the clock is
our days are 20 minutes and Magnus 32
minutes we have again it's very hard to
find a move for algorithm like I said
you cannot move this as this would hang
the Queen doesn't really have any good
moves the bishop is pointing at pretty
much at nowhere you still have to keep
an eye on the e4 pawn it's really being
pressured so it's a really tough
position for now for white and all it is
is burning his time very quickly so he
just goes back Knight e to F 1 and the
knight from here defends this night so
if you capture you can just capture back
and the e4 pawn will will still be
nicely defended and also maybe the
knight can maybe you can bring this
night perhaps here to trade off some of
the pieces so maybe this guy can come to
g3 Magnus pushes h4 he doesn't allow
Knight the g3 now or anytime in the
future
so all it as it goes Knight back to e3
and that's a lot of Knight F 193 Knight
of 193
from from the young Challenger
and again he wants to go Knight to g4
now that the H pawn moved to the age 40
G Foursquare has been vacated
but now Magnus goes Bishop therefore he
doesn't want tonight tonight the g4 to
come with an attack on the knight and
the bishop so Bishop to f4 and now again
night ETF one you still can't make a
better move with the night for example
if you try something like knife the see
for the triumph rate of something you
just open up a discovery from the roof
Knight captures here you agree you grab
a pawn and you win back your piece so
it's not not an issue so ali reza just
goes back knights the f1 and now Magnus
goes Queen to c7 now there's an there's
a more straightforward approach for
example nights the h7 followed by Knight
to g5 you take away the Queen and the
knight from GF I will again be
pressuring me for pawn so it's a
seemingly better square for the knight
but Queen to c7 is even better as Ali
Reza is low on time and Quinta c7
doesn't give out a raise or anything to
calculate here Magnus just says I have a
better position there is nothing to
calculate here there are no tactics you
just have to make a well a strategically
valid plan while you're well or clock is
a well running out and here
again there's a there is no active move
to make for example if you try making
some trades let's say Bishop captures
and c5 Magnus will just capture on f1
trying to remove one of the defenders of
d4 pawn you cannot capture with the King
because the knight Hanks so you'd have
to go Knight captures an f1 now comes
Queen captures on c5 and well now the
bishop ranks after there should be three
Queen d4 is coming now attacking the a4
pawn the rook is coming to c3 and it's
just an overwhelming position for black
so ali reza cannot even make a simple
trade here which is pretty much the only
trade that he can go go for so for the
lack of a better move he goes to g3 he
has to play something and okay
H capture sent g3f captures and g3 and
Magnus just goes back Bishop to h6 and
here
ali reza is under five minutes and this
has only moved 33 so he still had and
needs to make seven more
to reach time control and here he goes
h4 so what what do you do here here
Magnus goes for Queen to d7 it's it's an
attempt well he wants to grab da for
pawn he wants to bring the rook into the
game he wants to activate the Queen
there was also the possibility of going
Queen to a7 threatening all sorts of
nasty discoveries like that like Phillip
did against Martin and well after king
h1
now you go Knight cd7 and now you
threaten well Queen d4 and rook to c3
and it's not possible for for this to be
defended the bishop hangs well the rook
is attacking it if you move it you don't
really have a good square for it but
should be three then the rook comes into
the game and if rook b3 now you have a
very clean tactic Bishop captures and e2
Knight captures rook a person b3 Knight
captures and b3 and now Bishop captures
and d3 Queen captures and for example
Queen to f2 and again it's just just an
overwhelming position for for black so
this is one way to go about it
Queen to a7 Magnus goes for d4 a very
similar approach which is Queen to d7
Alireza goes King to g1 King to g2 there
is no point in trying to guard the pawn
here for example if you try something
like Queen d1 again just Bishop captures
and f1 is incredibly strong Knight
captures night chapters here and the
hope whole position falls apart for
white so King G to Biola RISM and now
comes Knight captures on a4 and okay
Bishop captures we have Queen captures
finally some characters on the board and
then now ali reza plays in Bishop
captures and d6
grabbing grabbing a very important point
creating a passed pawn of his own but
now Queen to d4 by Magnus again asking
what you want to do just threatening
that Knight captures captures is coming
so what do you play here here and it's
even better Queen d4 is even better than
Bishop captures an f1 here because here
you don't have to capture with the night
you can actually capture with the rook
and now you're threatening this and even
though it's okay for black to allow this
you can actually go for this after king
h6 white doesn't have a way to continue
the attack
still it's there's no point in allowing
this so Magnus just goes Queen d4
Alireza goes Queen to f2 it's well you
have to play something you have to
defend the night so Queen f2 it's the
strongest move by the engine but to tell
little avail so Queen captures on f2 by
Magnus King captures and now worship
characters on f1 and it was in this
position on move 39 that Alireza future
resigned the game and Magnus gets his
second victory in the tournament here
are all eras are resigned because if you
capture it well the knight is saying so
obviously capture with the knight Knight
captures but now Knight captures only
for check picks up the bishop on d6 so
King G - knife captors here you are just
down upon and also there is a line here
there is a line that the engine actually
prefers a Knight to g4 followed by rook
to c2 here at the cross and the bishop
captures an f-14 for the sole reason
because after Bishop captures King
captures you can give up the night here
Bishop captures here and now you play
Bishop captures on e5 and now ali reza
is down a piece but he does have these
two pawns
it's not much but a Lovaza doesn't feel
like like even trying to play this
position against Magnus so yeah now
after Bishop captures an f1 others are
resigned and a very important victory
for Magnus who catches up to algorithm
now and we are going to show at least
one more game from round 9 so we are
going to check out the standings then so
you might you might have noticed I
didn't ask you to pause the video in
this game that there was no reason to
there was no mistake by ali reza for for
magnus to punish it was just a small
small you know increments of advantage
being gained by on each move and in the
end the other races position just
deteriorated on its own it was just it
was impossible to keep making good moves
he kept burning too much time and it was
just well it was a it was a good taste
of what it's like to play a World Chess
Champion and he played he played into
his Berlin which surely Magnus prepared
a lot for for his World Championship
match against Fabiano Caruana if Fabi
goes for
for at some point but then again he
didn't so there was no Alireza I
couldn't really know what to expect if
he challenges calls into a Berlin but
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I know a lot of you were very
much looking forward to seeing this game
I know I was so like I said I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Stephen Merchant
Andrew Maha Walt and matthew Miller for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check too on my previous video Sarah
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the Tata
Steel Nast restoration checking up on
the Women's World Chess Championship
match checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and when we catch some
breath of course continuing the Morphy
saga so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day